Scrambled egg whites,
a vegetable smoothie
or wholegrain cereal
with low fat milk.
That’s how pop megastar Beyoncé
described a bootylicious breakfast
a few years ago.
However eating cereal has declined
by over 11% over the past five years,
with 40% of millennials
dismissing it as inconvenient
because it involves washing up.
Meanwhile the kind of farming
that produces bacon and sausages
is criticised for contributing
to climate change
through the carbon
emissions it produces.
So by the year 2039
meat, cereal and even dairy
may be much harder to find
on the breakfast menu.
Instead, you might be
tucking into a plate of...
According to researchers
in the Netherlands,
insects cost less
to raise than cattle,
consume less water and don’t
really leave a carbon footprint.
Plus in many cultures
around the world,
in fact 30% of the
planet’s population,
they’re already considered
pretty tasty.
Robyn Shapiro,
founder of Seek Food says...
So, while a rasher of bacon
may become an illicit luxury
only available in a fancy restaurant,
crunchy nut cricket flakes
could mean starting the day
with a bowl of creepy crawlies
from your garden biosphere.
Probably not if you’re vegan
or vegetarian
like one in eight Britons now are.
Or how about lab meat
grown from animal stem cells,
with no need for real-life pigs or
chickens to become dead ones.
A guilt free slice of black pudding
where there’s blood on the plate
but not on your hands.
Maybe the thought of this
has you desperately reaching
for that one cup of coffee
you’re allowed per year
thanks to climate change rationing.
Researchers and chefs
including Heston Blumenthal,
have discovered that what
you hear can affect what you taste.
So in 2039, your coffee might
seem like its full of sugar
even though there
isn’t anything sweet in it
apart from the sound of music.
With immersive dining
experiences on the rise,
from medieval banquets
to murder mystery stories,
or even a gastro physics
journey through space,
could breakfast of the future
be less about traditional taste
and more about living out
your culinary dreams
in a flavour-filled fantasy land?
By 2039 it looks like most of us,
70% in fact, will live in cities.
To cut transport costs, maybe
we’ll want to grow the onions
to go with our stem cell
sausages more locally.
However, if the current
housing crisis continues
and luxury flats fill in
every remaining space,
where would we plant our greens?
Perhaps the answer is underground.
In cities around the world,
this is already happening.
Urban farmers swap
sunlight for LED light
and use a system called hydroponics
where plants are grown in water,
so there’s no need for soil,
despite being surrounded by it.
Perfect for farming seaweed,
widely considered a sustainable
superfood of the future.
With cities increasingly full of
people and traffic by 2039,
we may need new ways
to transport the ingredients
that end up in our breakfasts.
Could this be where drones fly in?
Following the rise of
takeaway delivery services,
a company in China
has been trialling drones
as a way of getting
food to customers.
If this takes off, maybe delivery
drivers will be a thing of the past.
However, would you be happy to have
a drone rather than a person
popping by with your music-infused
coffee or seaweed sandwich spread?
With increasing numbers
of us working flexibly,
perhaps the need for a quick
breakfast before dashing off to work
will no longer be necessary.
Maybe instead we’ll start
to actually treat breakfast
as the most important meal of the day
rather than just talking about it.
But whatever’s on your
wheat bran plate,
you probably won’t have
to wash it up afterwards
because you’ll be able to eat it.
Great news for if you’re
a 57-year-old millennial.
Thanks for watching.
Don’t forget to subscribe! :)